[Music]
jack
is with us jax in oregon what's up jack
hey you guys i've got a question for you
that will seem ridiculous
to other listeners but it's it's real to
me um
i'm 37 my wife and i just entered baby
step
seven yay wow yes
you're 100 debt free you're rocking
retirement and you're 37. you're a rock
star man
yeah and that sounds and it is exciting
and our net worth is just north of a
million dollars so we're
doing great so good um
but here's here's the struggle we face
now um
you know mathematically with our income
and with this savings
this will turn easily into several
million by the time it's
it's time to retire 10 or 20. now
yeah i i struggle with a sense of
purpose now it almost feels like i'm
working for nothing
i don't know what to do with you know
i've got more money than i could
possibly
use when you're when you're working on
paying off a house
that's a motivator yep um everything's
gone
right so now you know writing checks for
charity
that doesn't it doesn't always satisfy
me it's just a check i don't see the end
result
um leaving a ton of money to my kids it
doesn't feel satisfying i feel like that
just puts them in the same problem i'm
facing right now
we don't spend a ton that doesn't
satisfy me to spend time i
it's just i struggle when i say so you
have discovered that
money is not the answer to happiness
yeah that's awesome
very cool good for you so now what well
i'm gonna tell you jack
the reason you feel the way you feel is
because you're realizing that we were
created to work
genesis chapter 2 is where we first
realized this that we don't work to live
we live to work in other words let me
say it a different way
we were created to contribute and what
you're longing for right now
is some work to get up every day and to
go do
something that matters to you and this
is where the answer is to your future
you're 37 money's not an object
when people call the ken coleman show
and they get a little stuck there's the
age-old question it's not
unique to me and i just simply say if
money did not matter
i guarantee you success you could not
fail and you just get to go
do something tomorrow that matters to
you that's when it breaks for people and
they begin to say well i want to help
people so i'm going to give you three
questions that you and your wife need to
answer and this is going to give you a
lot of clues okay here they are number
one
who are the people you most want to help
just think of those people
now what problem or challenge or desire
do they have and then what are the
solutions to that need that desire
when you begin to get the answers to
those questions and you match it up with
what you do very well this is what you
bring to the marketplace the skill to
actually bring the solution dave
the answers are in there and there's
multiple things they can do that's
what's exciting
and change your charitable giving where
you get your hands dirty yeah
down in the giving where you meet the
people and it'll change the it'll change
the visceral
reaction your gut has your spirit has to
charitable giving to generosity okay we
bumped up into a break on that i want to
keep that discussion going a little bit
ken
ken coleman ramsey personality my
co-host today on the air
it turns out a pile of money does not
make you happy
now we all kind of knew that the poets
told us our second grade teacher told us
and our grandmother told us
uh and yet we thought we tried anyway
sure so
why not right yeah yeah so
what it does do what apollo money does
do is it does
lower your stress on
things that make you desperate like
taking care of your kids
and basics like food shelter clothing
and those kinds of things
what it does do what it increases your
stress over is the more crap you own the
more repairmen you have to know
i swear the number of things i'm having
fixed all the time
and uh it's because i own a bunch of
crap you know i own a bunch of stuff so
i got a you know a 200 000 square foot
building here yeah you know we have
tornado winds hit it the other day and
tore out some beautiful trees
unbelievable cost us seventy thousand
dollars to have the trees cut up they
were just
bazillions of them they're gorgeous and
at three hundred thousand dollars worth
of damage the top of the building
and all i was in most i was under
insurance but the whole hassle of the
thing and if you don't own that you
don't have to worry about that when the
wind comes through you know so
it's not a problem so on and on we go
such things to cry about right
yes but uh but but the
the point is is it doesn't you trade one
set of problems for another set of
problems first
the second thing is is that our spirits
are not designed to be satisfied
by non-spiritual things
whether it's stuff uh substance abuse
uh you know addiction mentality on
uh pornography sex uh
cocaine heroin alcohol
people try to find something
to put into themselves all of us the
human runs around their whole life
looking for that thing to make us happy
and for those of us that are christians
we have found
personally yeah that god fills that and
that you get this
godliness with contentment is great gain
you get this the peace that passes all
understanding
and aside from the sermonette that i'm
diving into
the thing you start to realize on a
practical level when you get to baby
step
seven and you're you have a level of
wealth that young man 37 years old is a
millionaire already and he's obviously
making bank
we didn't ask who his income was but
it's probably a couple of hundred or
more
and so he's killing it and yet he's
still
and now he kind of got to the top of the
mountain and he's like what now
yeah so what your point was was there's
something to be done you're designed to
strive
and in the striving there is dignity
yeah
we we're created to work to contribute
so we're looking we're made in the image
of our creator and he
is a creator that's right that's exactly
right well hey look i mean
bottom line is if you just want to dive
behind this the theologies go read
genesis chapter 2 and watch what happens
and so he's created the world and now he
tells adam and eve to go subdue the
earth and the the the greek behind that
that
is is to create and so the idea is that
when you go out and work you create a
result
all work creates a result and and and
when we look at
the journey for all of us i've got seven
stages to
meaningful work to significance the
final stage is give yourself away
the idea here is is that when we get to
a point where we're living in our
purpose and we're contributing that role
that the creator gave us
to to fill then there's tremendous
meaning and significance and success
what the world defines as success comes
with that so
you know again i said this before on the
show i'll say it again
just to crystallize this for folks when
when chris hogan and ramsay solutions
did the largest study of net worth
millionaires that the world has ever
seen 10 000 plus
the third largest group of net worth
millionaires were teachers who
you know you're looking at in the
american you know just the general the
median income there dave is probably
between 50 to 60
000 maybe even lower in certain areas of
the country
and the point is is that they have
tremendous meaning they know that they
were created to instruct
if i was going to pick a one word to
describe their unique role it's
instructor and they love instructing
and they love teaching and guiding and
so they have found something that
gives them tremendous meaning so they
live on less than they make and they're
not making a ton of money but they're
making enough
and turns out they can be a millionaire
with enough and
and so that's the idea here and that
young man 37
he just has to figure out at this point
how do i give myself away i have lived
like no one else
and i love that you've you've said this
for years you live like no one else
now you can give like no one else and
it's not just the charitable giving he
said that
he goes i can't get any meaning out of
writing a check right now
well it's because he's not getting his
hands on it you get meaning out of your
charitable
out of your generosity when you're
involved that's it you got to get down
in it
you want to produce something well you
want to be in you know participate in
the ministry that you're supporting in
some way
other than just writing a check from
afar that's right i mean you can do that
and there's nothing wrong with that but
if you want the generosity to feed your
soul
when you're being generous then you've
got to be in the thing that's
number one number two is and that's this
is what i have done
yes absolutely personally i
and i get great meaning
from and i work my tail off and i
haven't had to work
for decades that's right uh because i
enjoy running the business
i enjoy the ministry of what we do i
enjoy
doing this show i enjoy working with you
personalities and watching your careers
blast off of the platform that i created
i enjoy watching the ramsey kids getting
the saddle for the next generation to
handle this place as a succession plan
unfolds i enjoy
every bit of that and i work really
really hard at it but none of that
is for money anymore it hasn't been for
money for a long long time
um i think of the email you read from
staff a meeting about three weeks ago i
believe it was a young lady
uh i believe from southeast asia who you
know literally transformed her life not
just financially but spiritually
and and you were reading the email to us
and you got choked up as you recalled
you were doing the math in your head you
know behold she was because she revealed
an email how old she was and that was
you know about the time you were trying
to sell a book out of a car
based on extreme pain that you had gone
through she was born yeah that's when
she was born and you were doing the math
and you're like
i did not know when i'm in that hot
shower that you've told and you're going
what do i do or when you're selling
books out of the back of the car or
you're
using one of those uh projectors on a
church wall
you had no idea the impact but you just
knew this is what i'm supposed to do
and this is why i'm supposed to do it
and you don't do it for the numbers
you do it for the one person the one
person
god takes care of the numbers yeah
that's exactly right
and it's that so in your career you got
to find
meaning in your work and work that has
meaning and
in your giving you have to connect to
that um
because you know as soon as you get to
the top of the mountain of money and
it's a pile of money
you're going to go it's not enough and
we never told you it was enough we just
said do it anyway
because it's the op the other options be
broke and you got another set of
problems that's right
and so retiring with you know dog food
on the table because you're
you know trying to live on social
insecurity counting on a government that
can't add to take care of you and your
old age now that's dumb
okay so instead of doing that let's have
these other set of problems
that are existential problems and let's
let's
wrestle through the theology and the
philosophy of life
and uh our spiritual walk and our
careers and what are we getting meaning
out of
and so because here's what we have told
you all along i told you this in the
legacy journey and hogan told you in
everyday millionaires as well
that when you get money the things in
your life are going to
magnify the crazy in your life is going
to get crazier
the people who are depressed become
unbelievably depressed when they get
money
if they don't heal their depression and
walk through a healing with that
at a time bad marriages get worse crazy
kids get
crazier bad jobs get more toxic
nothing gets it all gets larger and the
good things get larger too
compassionate people become unbelievably
peace you just see peace on their
countenance
when they when they get money and so
whatever it is all the good parts of
your character in the good parts of your
life and the bad parts of your character
and the bad parts of your life are going
to be magnified
so if you're dissatisfied with your job
and you get a bunch of money
do not expect the job dissatisfaction to
get better
expect it to get worse so go ahead and
do the ken coleman stuff
while you're working the baby steps